A BREAKAWAY GROUP OF MIGRANTS
FROM THE CARAVAN MOVING THROUGH
GUATEMALA HAS REPORTEDLY REACHED
THE BORDER WITH MEXICO.
THIS COMES HOURS AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATENED TO
SEND IN THE MILITARY TO SECURE
THE BORDER IF THE MIGRANTS
AREN'T STOPPED.
THE PRESIDENT BLAMING DEMOCRATS
FOR THE NEW CRISIS ON TWITTER,
CLAIMING THEIR SUPPORT OF WEAK
IMMIGRATION LAWS IS MAKING THE
SITUATION WORSE.
MEANWHILE, NANCY PELOSI IS
PUTTING HER FOOT DOWN SAYING HER
PARTY ISN'T PLANNING ON WORKING
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SHE SAYS, I'M SORRY I DON'T SEE
ANY OF US VOTING FOR WALL
FUNDING.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
SECURE OUR BORDERS.
THERE ARE WEIGHTS TO THAT
CONSISTENT WITH CIVILIZATION,
HUMANITARIANISM, AND WHO WE ARE
AS A NATION.
WE HAVE TO REMOVE ALL DOUBT
ABOUT THAT.
WITH ONLY 19 DAYS GOING TO THE
MIDTERMS, A NEW FOX NEWS PROCESS
WITH EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
VOTERS.
46% STATES IMMIGRATION.
I WANT US SHOW THIS OTHER ONE.
FOX NEWS POLL SAYING BORDER
SECURITY IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE AT 58%,
DENIGRATE AT 35% -- DEMOCRAT OF3
DENIGRATE AT 35% -- DEMOCRAT OF%
DENIGRATE AT 35% -- DEMOCRAT OF.
THIS NEW CARAVAN MOVING ITS WAY
NORTH, NOT GOOD TIMING FOR
DEMOCRATS.
>> Jesse: VISUALLY IT HAS A
BIG IMPACT ON VOTERS WHEN THEY
SEE THIS.
IT'S NOT A THEORETICAL PROBLEM.
NOT JUST THIS ONE CARAVAN.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT, IN TERMS
OF SIZE, CARAVANS LIKE THIS ARE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER ALL DAY
EVERY DAY, AND THERE'S REALLY
NOT WE CAN DO ABOUT IT BECAUSE A
LOT OF THESE LOOPHOLES ARE BAKED
INTO OUR IMMIGRATION AND ASYLUM
SYSTEM.
IT USED TO BE ADULT MALE
MEXICANS CROSSING THE BORDER.
NOW IT'S MOSTLY FAMILIES AND
TEENAGERS FROM GUATEMALA AND
FROM HONDURAS.
WE CAN'T TURN THEM BACK.
THE MEXICANS YOU COULD, BUT YOU
HAVE TO BRING IN AND TAKE, WHEN
YOU APPREHEND THEM, INTO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE CLAIMING CREDIBLE FEAR.
CREDIBLE FEAR, THAT EXCUSE HAS
SPIKED OVER THE COUPLE YEARS.
YET WHEN THEY USE IT, THE
ECONOMY IN HONDURAS IS GOING UP,
YET CRIME IN HONDURAS IS GOING
DOWN.
IT MAKES ME BELIEVE THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE BEING COACHED.
YOU ARE HEARING THINGS LIKE
NGOs SENDING ACTIVISTS AND
LAWYERS DOWN TO CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES AND THEY ARE HELPING
THEM WITH THE CARAVAN.
THEY ARE COACHING THEM ON WHAT
TO SAY WHEN THEY GET TO THE
BORDER.
IT'S INTERESTING.
WHERE DO THEY GET THE CAMERAS
FROM?
WE ARE HEARING A LOT OF THESE
NGOs ARE BRINGING THESE CAMERA
CREWS IN AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THE
PEOPLE GET OFF THE VAN, THEY
WALK WHEN THE CAMERA CREWS COME
OUT.
THE CAMERA CREW STOP REPORTING
AND THEY HOPPED IN THE VAN.
ONCE I GET TO MEXICO, THEY PAY
THE DRUG CARTELS AND THE
SMUGGLERS $5,000 PER FAMILY UNIT
TO GET THEM ACROSS.
THE DRUG CARTELS ARE THE ONLY
ONES MAKING ANY MONEY IN THIS
PROCESS.
THE DRUG CARTELS AND THE OPEN
BORDER DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE ON
THE SAME SIDE.
THESE DRUG CARTELS HAVE MADE
$2.5 BILLION IN SMUGGLING ALONE
PER YEAR.
THAT'S ON TOP OF THE DRUG
PROFITS, AND THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE
IMMIGRATION LAWS SO THAT YOU
TREAT PEOPLE WHO CROSS THE
BORDER IF YOU ARE FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA THE SAME WAY YOU
DO IS IF YOU ARE FROM CANADA AND
MEXICO.
>> Dana: KENNEDY, THE OTHER
THINGS, IN THESE CARAVANS,
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
REPORTING THAT THE NUMBER OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT TAPPING ALONG
THIS ROUTE AND NOT JUST -- IN
THE CARAVAN, AS JESSE WAS
SAYING, 1600 MIGRANTS TRY TO
CROSS THE BORDER A DAY.
THEY ARE FINDING REPEATED
INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT, FOR
CHILDREN EVEN.
THIS IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
BOARD.
>> Kennedy: IT'S HORRIBLE.
WE SAW SOME OF THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE SHELTERS IN
THE AFTERMATH OF HURRICANE
FLORENCE.
IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE ASPECT OF
HUMAN NATURE.
WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO LET
REALLY GOOD PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY AND KEEP REALLY BAD
PEOPLE OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
THE GOVERNMENT HASN'T DONE THAT
AND I THINK PART OF IT REST ON
CONGRESS BECAUSE WE HAVE GOT A
VERY CONFUSING IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS, I AM
CONVINCED THIS IS THE ONE ISSUE
WHERE THEY WILL NEVER WORK
TOGETHER BUT IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A PRESIDENT,
EVEN THOUGH HE'S BEHIND        H
EVEN THOUGH HE'S BEHIND        R
EVEN THOUGH HE'S BEHIND        -
EVEN THOUGH HE'S BEHIND        I
EVEN THOUGH HE'S BEHIND        E
EVEN THOUGH HE'S BEHIND        R
RHETORICALLY AND IMMIGRATION,
THERE'S A LOT HE WOULD GIVE TO
DEMOCRATS IN ORDER TO COME UP
WITH COMPROMISE.
I DON'T THINK YOU WOULD SEE THAT
WITH THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND REPUBLICANS IN THE SAME WAY
OR WITH PAST REPUBLICANS
ADMINISTRATIONS.
THEY NEED TO FIX IT.
IF YOU THINK BY THE KIND PEOPLE
YOU WANT TO HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY, YOU WANT PEOPLE ARE
HARDWORKING COME PEOPLE WHO ARE
ETHICAL, PEOPLE WHO LOOK OUT FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
VERY PHYSICALLY STRONG.
I THINK WE NEED TO SET UP AN
AMERICAN NINJA WARRIOR AT THE
BORDER AND WHOEVER CAN MAKE IT
-- CAN'T MAKE IT.
>> Dana: THE UNITED STATES IS
TRYING TO HELP THOSE COUNTRIES
WITH AID, CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM, CRIME IS GOING DOWN IN
HONDURAS AND GUATEMALA AND YET
THE CARAVAN STILL COME.
>> Juan: I THINK ITS ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS THAT LEAD FAMILIES TO
DECIDE THAT THEIR BEST PROSPECT
IS TO COME TOWARD THE
UNITED STATES.
AS WE KNOW, THEIR ECONOMIES HAVE
BEEN SUFFERING.
I THINK THAT'S THE PRINCIPLE
REASON.
I'M INTERESTED IN THIS AS A
POLITICAL PLOY BY REPUBLICANS
BECAUSE CLEARLY IMMIGRATION IS
NOT A BIG ISSUE IN THIS
CAMPAIGN.
ACCORDING TO THE POLLS, 7% OF
PEOPLE SAY IT'S A BIG ISSUE.
AND THAT THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IS
HEALTH CARE.
>> Kennedy: ACCORDING TO THE
POLL DANA JOE SHALL COMMENCE
NUMBER FOUR.
>> Juan: EXTREME PEOPLE.
THE BIG ISSUE IS HEALTH CARE NEW
START LOOKING AT THE SECONDARY
ISSUE, RANDY AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND THE THIRD
ONE IS PEOPLE WHO WANT DEMOCRATS
TO CONTROL THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT THIS
ISSUE?
WE HAVE TIME TO TALK ABOUT THIS
OTHER ISSUES BUT WHAT ABOUT
NANCY PELOSI SAYING THAT THEY
WON'T WORK WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TO ME, IT'S NOT A RIGHT AND LEFT
ISSUE.
IT'S EFFECTIVE YOU HAVE A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, WITH
CHILDREN BEING SENT TO THE
HOSPITAL AS THEY HAVE TO STOP AT
WEIGH STATIONS.
THEY ARE DEHYDRATED.
SOME OF BEEN VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
IF THEY GET HERE -- IT'S NOT
TRUE?
>> Juan: I SAID IT'S NOT GOOD.
>> Dana: NOT GOOD.
WHY WOULD NANCY PELOSI BE
SIGNALING?
>> Kennedy: I NEED TO PUSH
BACK ON YOU, JUAN.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT CORRECTION.
IT WASN'T EXTREME VOTERS.
IT WAS A POLL OF LIKELY VOTERS.
>> Juan: NO, NO, PEOPLE WHO
ARE EXTREME THE CONCERN.
>> Dana: AMONG THOSE WHO SAY
IT BORDER SECURITY IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
>> Juan: OKAY, I THINK YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND NANCY PELOSI
IS TALKING ABOUT THE WALL AND
ABOUT THE PRESIDENTS PERSISTENCE
-- I THINK YESTERDAY WE QUOTED
HER AS SAYING THAT IT WAS A
MANHOOD ISSUE.
IT'S A POLITICAL ISSUE.
HE SEES IT AS A PROMISE HE MADE
WAS BASIN HE WANTS TO DELIVER
FIRST BASE BUT IF YOU GO BACK IN
TIME, REMEMBER GOING BACK TO
PRESIDENT BUSH,
PRESIDENT OBAMA, YOU ARE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
WORKING ON THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE, WORKING ON BORDER
SECURITY.
TRUMP HAS MADE IT ALL ABOUT THE
WALL, AND WHAT NANCY PELOSI IS
SAYING HEY, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
THE WALL.
IT'S NOT A GOOD EXPENSIVE MONEY
OR TIME AND CERTAINLY NOT TO BE
MEAN TO PEOPLE.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
NANCY PELOSI SAYS IS THIS IS NOT
WHO WE ARE AS A NATION.
>> Greg: IT'S A COP-OUT.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AS JUAN SAID,
BILL CLINTON, PRESIDENT OBAMA
UNDERSTOOD BORDER SECURITY HELPS
TO FIND A COUNTRY AND LIKE IT OR
NOT, THE WALL IS ACTUALLY PART
OF BORDER SECURITY.
HOW COULD IT NOT BE?
WE HAVE FENCES.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT INTERESTED
IN PUTTING UP A WALL.
IF YOU ARE ON SAFARI AND YOU ARE
BEING CHASED BY A RINO, YOU
HAPPEN TO THE FIRST ROCK.
YOU DON'T WAIT FOR THE FOURTH
ONE.
THERE'S A HUGE DISHONESTY GOING
ON.
THEY IGNORE THE LAND BETWEEN
HONDURAS AND GUATEMALA AND THE
UNITED STATES.
IMAGINE HOW MANY LIVES WILL BE
SAVED AND HOW MANY RAPES WOULD
BE PREVENTED IF THEY WERE ABLE
TO STOP.
ONCE THEY LEAVE THEIR COUNTRY
AND LAY CLAIM TO SOME LAND
RATHER THAN RISKING THEIR LIVES
MAKING IT TO THE BORDER.
IT'S A HUGE HYPOCRISY THAT
SOMEHOW WE ARE ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO MAKE THIS TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE JOURNEY BECAUSE -- FOR
SOME KIND OF POLITICAL OPTICS.
I HATE USING THE WORD OPTICS.
TO YOUR POINT, WHERE IS THE
ME TOO MOVEMENT?
YOU ARE PUTTING WOMEN IN DANGER
FOR THIS ISSUE.
WHERE ARE YOU?
HOW CAN YOU ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN?
THAT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY
DISGUSTING.
>> Kennedy: YOU MAKE A GOOD
POINT ABOUT MEXICO.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS TO MAKE
YOU TAKE SOME OF THE HYPERBOLE
AND RHETORIC OUT OF IT AND YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING, HE'S APPEALING TO
MEXICO.
ASIDE FROM THREATENING TO SHUT
DOWN THE SOUTHERN BORDER, BUT
THEY DO HAVE SOME RESPONSIBILITY
HERE, AND THEY DO OPEN UP BOTH
BORDERS IN ORDER TO SOME PEOPLE
FURTHERMORE WITH.
IT'S A HUMANITARIAN ISSUE.
MEXICO IS A HUMANITARIAN COUNTRY
WITH PEOPLE WHO CARE VERY MUCH
ABOUT THEIR FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS TO THE NORTH AND
SOUTH, THEN WHY DON'T THEY HAVE
BETTER SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO
ABSORB SOME OF THE REFUGEES?
>> Greg: THE OTHER LIE IS THAT
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS MAKE YOUR LIFE
-- PUT YOUR LIFE IN THREAT.
IT'S LIKE NO, IT'S LIKE STAY IN
THE COUNTRY AND DEAL WITH THESE
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS.
>> Juan: WE HAVE A HISTORY IN
AMERICA PEOPLE FROM CUBA GETTING
ON THE HIGH SEAS.
>> Greg: WHEREVER THERE IS
LEFTISM, THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE ARE
IN DANGER.
>> Juan: THERE'S A HISTORY OF
PEOPLE PUTTING THEMSELVES AT
GREAT RISK IN ORDER TO REACH OUR
SHORES BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IN
AMERICA.
THEY LIKE THE FINANCIAL
OPPORTUNITY.
>> Greg: THERE IS SOMETHING
BETWEEN HERE AND THEY ARE:
MEXICO.
>> Juan: WE HAVE A BETTER,
STRONGER ECONOMY THAN MEXICO.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE A MENU OF
OPTIONS YOU CAN CHOOSE FROM.
>> Juan: I'M TELLING YOU
THAT'S WHAT FAMILIES ARE FOCUSED
ON.
I THINK THEY ARE FOCUSED ON
THEIR CHILDREN.
>> Dana: WANT TO GO BACK TO
SOMETHING JESSE SAID.
THAT IS THAT THE DRUG CARTEL,
APPARENTLY THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
PERSON THAT'S COME ACROSS THE
BORDER BUT HASN'T HAD TO PAY
SOME SORT OF MONEY AS A FAMILY
OR INDIVIDUAL TO THE DRUG
CARTELS.
PERHAPS THERE IS SOMETHING THAT
HE COULD FIND A BIPARTISAN
AGREEMENT, FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
HER TARGET OF THE DRUG CARTELS,
THE LEADERS OF THEIR FINANCES,
AND SHUT THEM DOWN.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE MAKING
FISTFULS OF CASH EVERY DAY FROM
THE SMUGGLING OPERATIONS ON TOP
OF THE PROFITS THEY ARE MAKING
FROM HEROIN, COCAINE, AND
MARIJUANA.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THE POSITION THEY ARE IN BY
HAVING OPEN BORDERS POLICIES
ONLY EMPOWERS THE DRUG CARTELS.
IT EMPOWERS NO ONE ELSE.
ONLY THE DRUG CARTELS.
I AM HAPPY THAT JUAN WOULD ADMIT
THAT THE TRUMP ECONOMY IS SO
STRONG, PEOPLE ARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES TO COME TO AMERICA TO GET
A PIECE OF THE PIE.
>> Juan: I SAID THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
BY THE WAY, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
I DON'T GET IT.
YOU ACT AS IF THERE IS NOTHING